from their first animated short in 1997
to onward in 2020 Pixar has evolved a
lot animals look more real we went from
smooth fur to seeing every moving strand
and human characters went from stiff to
natural and cute but there's another
area of innovation that you might not
have noticed in the 25 years Pixar's
been around close the studio has come a
long way since the suit jacket in 1997's
Jerry's game such a long way that an
entire character in 20 20 s onward is
just made of a pair of pants to see just
how far they've brought their cloth
technology you just have to look at how
they animated the dad in onward a
central character in a Pixar movie will
have their clothing built from scratch
starting with the whole set of sketches
and concept art this design stage is
especially important when the costume
figures prominently into the story as
dad's does in onward the film's premise
is that these brothers use a magic spell
to connect with their late father but
are only able to conjure up the bottom
half of him his pants they improvise an
upper half for their dad out of an old
sweatshirt some pillow stuffing gloves
and a trucker hat which meant all of
this had to seem thrown together but in
a funny endearing way it needs to be
appealing right we need to believe both
that he could that you could be a
sweatshirt but maybe from squinting out
of the corners you are like oh that
might be a real person once the
characters wardrobe is designed all the
art reference gets handed over to
Pixar's character tailoring artists who
basically act as digital tailors for the
film it's their job to worry about every
single piece of clothing you see in a
movie like onward their first task is to
bring the clothes into virtual form by
modeling them in the computer they build
a 3d shape or model of each garment then
fit it on to the character model also
known as the skin as part of the fitting
process they'll take the character
through a series of animated poses to
see how the clothing fits this is where
things got tricky with dad his lower
body was like a traditional character
there was an animated skin underneath
those pants
but his upper half was supposed to be
made of cloth and stuffing with no skin
or bodily structure underneath it here's
where the next stage simulation came in
simulation is a way to automate the
movement of elements like clothing fur
and hair that would take too long to
animate by hand
Pixar first used cloth simulation in
1997's Jerry's game a five-minute short
that was shown before a bug's life in
theaters at first
Jerry's baggy suit wouldn't fit with his
movement outside of the default tipos
when he lowered his arms for example the
fabric bunched up in his armpits Steve
Jobs suggested they ask designer Giorgio
Armani for tailoring help instead they
came up with a long term solution
writing a software for a simulator that
would govern the jackets behavior by
2001 s Monsters Inc Pixar had set up a
dedicated simulation department and
built a simulator engine called fisty
which helped control the folding of
booze loose t-shirt fisty is the same
program used on onward it basically
functions like a computer calculating
how Clause should realistically respond
to a character's movements and
surroundings how it should move with the
character's body and in response to
different forces for that we need motion
from the animation Department on the
character the character animator moves
the lower body around like they walk the
legs around and we start simulating it
but because dad's upper half is all
clothes and no body simulation played an
even more important role than usual we
had to make him believable like that
it's really all the motions driving from
his hips since his arms don't have
muscles in them they just need to kind
of flop around which it can be a really
challenging thing to animate
there are a bunch of shots in the movie
where the entire upper body the blue
vest the gray sweatshirt the hands which
are actually just like ROM work the
gloves and hand the glasses are all
simulated there's a lot of sort of
interplay between the animation in the
simulation there and making it feel both
kind of intentional but also believable
that it's not really a person in there
since dad's upper half is basically a
lump of stuffing it required what's
called a volumetric sim a simulation for
something that's thick and has volume to
make this stuff in
nice and cushy they use technology from
an unlikely source
the octopus Hank from finding dory a
film that Chris actually worked on the
scene that introduced Hank in that movie
took a full two years to make and in the
final version
a lot of Hanks charm comes from his
squishy-squashy motion the volumetric
simulation is squishing it up Hank with
the precursor to the squishiness for dad
another beloved Pixar film that Chris
worked on coca also helped lay the
groundwork for the advanced level of
cloth simulation and onward the intense
layering of cloth and complexity in
detail that we got from cocoa made it
possible for us to make more complex and
interesting characters on on work and
just the speed of our simulator got a
lot better so dad wouldn't have been
possible without the work that was done
on cocoa as viewers we have an intuitive
understanding for how clothes should
move on a body and if simulation does
its job those cloth dynamics will look
natural on-screen but when looking at
clothes we also instinctively know how
light should reflect off a certain
surface and where we might see scratches
or fraying threads or pilling that's
where we get to the shading or surfacing
part of the process when picks our
shading artists add highly detailed
patterns tints and finishes to make each
garment look true-to-life we see a
variety of different fabrics on the
characters and onward and each is
treated differently by pixar shading
artists have the advantage of many years
of shading technologies developed for
earlier productions like 2012's brave
back then the challenge of shading
Marita's period dresses and her father's
16 layers of costume produced what the
studio calls loom technology this
program basically weaves every strand of
virtual fabric into a shading software
giving clothes richer detail and a more
tactile quality Pixar also made
breakthroughs in shading with 2018 s
Incredibles 2 since fashion is such a
big part of the Incredibles movies one
of Pixar's design goals for the second
film was to make their garment shading
work better with extreme character
movements like those of the highly
kinetic Elastigirl Pixar developed
technology to preserve fine texture and
illumination details in the characters
super suits even when the fabrics were
stretched or compressed
in onward shading really hopes to sell
the textures of the clothes on screen
the shiny leather of dodge shoes the
fuzziness of a sweatshirt and the
puffiness of his vest without any
shading work that best might look more
like plastic than the nylon material
it's supposed to be once the shading
artists get all the materials down they
add signs of wear and tear
like scuff marks on dad's shoes and
subtle stains on its vest when watching
the movie you probably wouldn't actively
notice these touches without them
without those imperfections that are
they're very specific handmade
imperfections it doesn't feel real
another way to make the clothes look
lived in is through Ringling which is
usually a collaborative project between
the tailoring and shading artists if we
take another look at the vest those
bigger wrinkles and bumps were modeled
into the garment by Chris as part of the
tailoring process the high-frequency
detailed wrinkles were done in shading
so the part where you could see the
puffiness cinch down into the seams
those very fine wrinkles are shaded
wrinkles wrinkled patterns are
customized for each individual garment
depending on what fabric they're
supposed to be and where the artistic
direction is going the wrinkles on the
face we wanted them to be wrinkly enough
that they felt like it could be a real
sweatshirt but they couldn't be so
wrinkly that it looked like a scary
monster for the tailor what that means
as we think about how it's how the
wrinkles should develop is so we'd have
a bunch of different head shape hoses
head tilted left held to the right and
and the transition between those poses
to make sure that the wrinkles that were
we were making felt right once every
single garment has the right amount of
texture it should be looking like real
world fabric which means the clothing
process is pretty much complete all
that's left is rendering all of the
shots the final step in Pixar's
production pipeline the more advanced
Pixar's cloth simulation gets the more
power is needed to render each shot
monsters ink for example required more
rendering power than Pixar's three
previous features combined partly
because of how complex the cloth and
first simulation was relative to earlier
films
luckily the studio keeps developing
newer and faster processors to do the
job it's Pixar's blending of
state-of-the-art technology grounded in
hard math and physics with imaginative
fashion and art direction that makes its
costume design
which so appealing and let's an outfit
like dads play it's very own role in the
storytelling
[Music]